oh absolutely
great question I'm actively looking to
collect exactly that type of material I
do you remember the Aero satellite I
used to get in 1966 weekly mailings of
the black-and-white images and strips I
I wish I had kept them I didn't keep
them but we're looking for exactly that
type of material because it's a big part
of the story and fifty years from now a
hundred years from now that will that
will be a huge part of the story we're
also looking to preserve GIS the
products of GIS gulino's and Selene both
know a lot about that a lot of GIS work
that's done is what we would call a
little bit throw away and it's it's so
Stanford is so good in its library to
think about preserving the GIS tables
the databases the software itself so yes
by all means we we that's a big part of
the 20th century and that really ties to
long now foundation as well and log now
is working with Stanford and with the
map the map Center and and Julie back
here as I'm sure many of you know for
example the original data from the
Viking Lander all that stuff collected
at Norman
cost can't be read because there's no
longer a machine around that can read
the tapes and besides the iron filings
are falling off so they're going to
tackle that stuff
[Music]